thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys we have with us on the hot
tea today Mr nimesh Patel
[Applause]
so the way these episodes work is you
are going to be in this very hot seat
we're going to be asking you a series of
questions that get a little more
intrusive as they go okay it just is a
good word lucky for you we always start
with Bart with who always just happens
to have the coldest possible question
why is the ridiculous ones but yes
okay here's the question man
do your best drowning impression
say it like a question that's pretty
good
that's the first request we got from
Clark
please don't Photoshop no dicks going in
my mouth
oh my God that's good because everyone's
isn't it drowning like a violent thing
yeah yeah it's very cool it's pretty
it's pretty bad yeah I mean people say
like it's like a myth that it's like a
quiet drown or you drown like very
violently yeah because I think you're
resisting right because you're holding
your breath you're resisting as much as
you can to the point that you can't and
the point that you can't is when you
usually inhale with all your might and
that's when the water is like
but doesn't that mean it's really only
excruciatingly [ __ ] up for like less
than 30 seconds but it'll feel like but
it's like pure Terror yeah yeah
so what's the way you don't want to die
the most fearful way that you just do
not want to die the most beautiful way
that I don't well drowning sounds pretty
bad push every just talked about it uh
uh stabbing I hear is [ __ ] brutal as
you're sitting in a sword full of a
chair full of Swords sad [ __ ]
right now but I just don't want to get
stabbed and this was a legit fear in New
York these days people walk around cut
you up has it ever almost happened no
thank God
what's one of the most uh what What's
some of the one of your biggest fears
standing again
uh honestly losing my memory oh wow like
I've seen like like my grandpa passed
away in December of last year but like
he was like sharp yeah I was very afraid
of just like I already forget [ __ ] all
the time I'm just like do I get a brain
to her like gaining Dementia or
Alzheimer's or something yeah it's
[ __ ] terrified you had a concussion
no not that I know of but uh yeah that
that's what scares me the most that's
probably my biggest fear that I've never
really articulated until right now but
yeah like just like forgetful for being
not like just having him not Amnesia but
like dementia and like yeah and it's
like who is everybody that that scares
the [ __ ] out of me so everyone in your
life matters a lot to you yes like it
would be so terrifying to like forget
people anybody you wouldn't even know
that that's happening yeah and to be
that to people you care about exactly
that sounds [ __ ] terrifying sorry to
be so serious
that is snakes uh
snakes is good yes Amnesia Venom yeah
there is like some sort of subconscious
because my Grandma had really bad uh
like Alzheimer's
and my grandpa passed away I think like
two or three years before my grandma
and she would just be like
where's grandpa like should you just
feel it you know and then like everyone
would oh God went to the grocery store
and then we would just try to cover up
you know like oh he'll be back he'll be
back because we know she's gonna forget
in five minutes yeah but as we cover up
like everyone in the family is like King
like cherry eye like oh this grocery
store you know yeah he's like oh okay
cool just tell him hurry up I'm like all
right we will
who are you boy
that'd be pretty funny like if I'm
watching from the outside but being in
that that's good [ __ ] I mean I don't
think I don't think that would be
enjoyable at all
sorry
so you on another episode you told us
about like your journey of being a
stand-up comedian but I have the age-old
Asian question that we totally skipped
which is how does your parents take all
of this it was right my parents uh uh
were questioning it at first uh then
they were like all right this is really
what he wants to do hopefully he can
make money somehow pay his own goddamn
rent and then uh at some point maybe uh
two three days ago they're like okay
good job two or three days ago
nice special no no it was uh it was uh
you know I think last year and this year
was when the full like all right he's
actually [ __ ] doing some crazy [ __ ]
because you know like to sell out
theaters and clubs like yeah yeah so
when you told him you were writing for
the Oscars I wasn't when I when I caught
I remember it distinctly and I called my
parents and told them
I was like guys do you know who's
hosting the Oscars this year like who
Chris Rock my mom was like which one was
that I don't care
I'm to educate them on what stand-up is
the writing Pro like what comedy is in
general not that they didn't know what
stand-up was but for them to have
someone in the world of Comedy is like
[ __ ] brand new like you don't know
what that is so they're they're
apprehension Came From Fear of like can
he make something out of himself doing
this as opposed to Comedy who wants to
[ __ ] do that yeah uh but now it's
like okay like I'm paying bills like
we're doing [ __ ] and not now in the last
year and a half where it's like
I'm on my own I'm doing my own [ __ ] like
I'm not depending on a job or anything
like that I just gotta make my own way I
think they finally like all right this
is a cool path you [ __ ] successful
they came to my special tape and they
saw you know 400 people twice sold out
in New York City like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] made it you know it was
like were they laughing my dad at one
point yes my dad at one point at the end
at the end of the the special I shout my
parents out for like uh uh what's it
called
hey being in the room or whatever and I
said my parents are here thank you for
being my dad got up I was like
love to do it the whole time that's my
boy I wish I had that on camera man like
my sister was sitting with him saying
dad got up and just waved him
yeah that's [ __ ] awesome next time
you need a dedicated dad camp
and that was the first time they came to
one of your shows no that's like the
third time yeah they came once or twice
yeah yeah but this was like the special
they took the night off and my dad works
a lot so like they took the night off
and came out and was just like this
[ __ ] dope do you have any bits about
your parents at my entire closing bid is
about uh uh how my parents caught me
smoking weed uh I did it on Fallon but
uh uh this is true story like I was
doing live streams on YouTube for like a
lot of pandemic just to like have
something to do and like write and [ __ ]
and part of it was like me getting high
and like just talking [ __ ] to camera
like just working out bits and my dad I
forgot because I was high probably that
my dad
like watches literally all of it
and so and so oh my God and so like I'm
doing the live stream and my dad will
watch me like on the live stream like
he'll just keep the phone on his like uh
um what's it called dashboard yeah while
he's driving home
and I'm live streaming at the time when
he's driving home from work at like nine
ten ten o'clock at night he's worth a
liquor store so
he like I remember getting the phone
call the next morning he didn't call he
like had to process it at night his son
is smoking weed alive so you were like
hitting a joint hitting a joint live hey
guys what's up YouTube you know like
seven people and
and my dad called me this morning and my
mom calls me actually my mom's like
dad's very upset with you what were you
smoking last night so it's like Mom it
was just wish like you need to stop my
dad was like you need to quit I told him
the bit is I told him to stop smoking
he's like I'm not gonna argue with you
like if you smoke cigarettes and it's
like quit smoking cigarettes I'll quit
smoking weeds like shut up
I know when I got you dad I know what I
got you but I understand where you're
coming from he's like not my cigarettes
yeah yeah exactly like no these New
Ports have been with me
they never talk back like you is he
cracking up at that joke yeah now he's
like uh you're welcome
that was me yeah I just waves again the
original bit the original bit was that
bit evolved but the original bit was uh
um
he caught me smoking weed and then you
know we were like weed was on the ballot
for New Jersey like to legalize it or
whatever and I was at home and I was
like Dad you got to vote for this and he
just like looks at the yes or no column
he just looks at me and says nope
that was it he's still he's still
against all that [ __ ] you know but they
can't really do anything about my drug
use because it's worked out
does it affect your performance knowing
that your parents are in the audience
not really the first one or two times it
did a little bit but you know the second
but that was the first time they came to
see me it was probably like you know
three or four years before the special
uh they saw me at the cellar
um uh but that you know at that point
it's like nah it don't matter I didn't
think about them being in the crowd
Beyond like when it was time to shout
them out it was just like all right they
I know they're rooting for me and I
can't see them so
I don't they already know all my stuff
you said you had like 16 first cousins
that came out in like washed your like
first show and stuff like that right
um do you feel like since you've taken
the Reigns of comedy and just kind of
doing something different has any of
your like uh family or immediate or
larger extended family anybody like
start kind of like thinking different
looking up to you and being like maybe I
don't want to you know be a doctor maybe
I want to be a funny man I hope I mean I
don't no one has broken from their
deviated from their past but that's the
Set uh you know of a second oldest but
in among the
eight eight siblings on my mom's side
and 10 on my dad's side wow
um uh but so but they were all like a
year or two apart so no one's really
been able to be like oh nemes did this
so now we're gonna do this yeah uh you
know I hope that some of the younger
ones the new generation like their kids
or whatever yeah I hope they can see
like oh you can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want uh but I do know that uh you know
some of my cousins who are a bit more
entrepreneurial like Nima is doing this
cool [ __ ] like we shouldn't be afraid to
strike out and do [ __ ] on our own too
that's cool did their parents use you as
an example like you want to be like your
cousin I hope so but in a way we're like
you want to end up like him no I mean
for a while I'm sure because for a while
it was like you know I was in and out of
jobs and all this kind of stuff and I'm
sure that was never something that uh my
cousins would want a pop for themselves
but now it's like you know the hard work
is paid off and they're all just like
can we get tickets to the show I'm like
yes of course you get tickets you get
tickets you know it's been fun I'm gonna
turn up the heat a little bit yeah these
are light yeah yeah yeah yeah mine is a
drowning thing
out of all the uh
Indian
comedians which one's the most overrated
[Laughter]
eyes he goes which ones uh
uh let's see the the Indian guy a pool a
pool is the most overwritten no I don't
know uh me probably
there's a safe answer man you gotta
understand something all these people
are my friends yeah that's true that's
true I would say so who's your favorite
Indie comedian then me that's the easy
one no not including you out of the ones
that are well I gotta shout Russell
Peters out uh I use your own team man I
don't think I would I wouldn't even
think
subconsciously if I think back at it you
know Russell was the first
Indian comic I ever saw and uh it was it
was 2004 when his special like leaked on
YouTube and my boy and I still did still
my friend to this day uh we my Floor
Mate at the time at NYU we bonded over
that special yeah and so Russell has
like this huge place in my heart and if
you watch my comedy now it's not on
purpose but it is definitely uh uh a
function of seeing like Russell was very
conversational uh when he talks to like
people in the crowd and stuff and and
not that not to say he's the first
person to ever invent crowd work or
anything like that but that style of
like I've emulated some of that I've
been like I'm gonna talk to the crowd
and then move into material and and that
is like by no small coincidence like a
function probably haven't seen him do
that and make it seem so like personal
and seamless you know like he does it
really well in that first special
especially which is the only special
I've seen uh uh someone's gonna get hurt
real bad where he's like talking the
crowd and somebody gotta get it
that special was one of the first
specials I think that made my stomach
hurt I'm laughing so hard yeah yeah
that's so much I show my parents that
special you know like like that was
probably one of the first specials we
watched together by one of three that
we've watched together the first one
being Dana Carvey is like whatever came
out in 96 or with chopping broccoli and
the second one being bigger and black
and the third one being Russell Peters I
even know what it's called that first
one uh the elite Canadian one yeah but
somebody gonna get a heart rate
but
that was like uh
a
seminal moment if I in my subconscious
at least to be like oh Russell Peters
the stand-up comedy like maybe that
could be something I pursue it was like
the first person to show that you can do
that kind of [ __ ] you know have you ever
wanted to joke about something but you
just like knew this too far you can't
what
AKA say the joke now I mean there was a
there was a moment where I was thinking
I forget which school shooting it was
good old school shooting jokes but it
was it was it was several years ago
before I've been passing it was like it
was I was at
stand up New York in uh uh Upper West
Side of Manhattan and uh I think it
would happen it happened just after the
school shooting
and I was I was just angry when I was on
stage because like the fact that we were
so apathetic to the shootings
then I went on stage like yeah a bunch
of kids died today you know and it was
just like it was like I don't know why
we're so upset people die all the time
and it was just it wasn't delivered
right even still like it doesn't hit
it's funny but in the moment it was
funny to me that we didn't give a [ __ ]
and and now if I ever touch the subject
if I which I do and uh uh thank you
China especially a little bit
yeah yeah uh I I do touch it very
Loosely
um
which again there's no necessarily third
rail I just had to figure out how to do
it but at the time that was one of those
things like I can't [ __ ] I shouldn't
joke about it and I tried doing it did
it [ __ ] fell on my face you know
everyone's like [ __ ] this guy it's like
yeah that's probably deserved in
Einstein
um
but no the short answer is no there's
nothing I won't joke about as long as I
think I can find something funny about
it right but there's also like
right now the comedy all feels like hot
takes about something
and so my current hour that I'm working
on is like deeply personal it's not uh I
mean I have some random Snippets of
what's going on in society and stuff but
for the most part it's like I've gone
the other way like I don't I I don't
watch the news I don't know what's going
on in the world like some of the some of
the stuff you said is very unfamiliar to
me most of it you know like I don't give
a [ __ ] like I realize that I gotta work
on think about me a lot right now and
and so there's nothing about me I won't
joke about it's cool has um becoming
famous
yeah I mean you're pretty pretty famous
compared to when you started yes for
sure for sure but yeah Mr dad's stand up
yeah yeah yeah he's being more famous in
the in the in the comedian World
affected in any way your relationship
with your wife not at all uh if anything
is solidified uh because I can always
I'm very proud of my curve game in the
sense that people people hit me in the
DMs like uh are you single yes but only
for my wife you know like that wow that
[ __ ] is it's so much it's fun to do that
and you know it's fine to reject people
it's not even rejection it's just like
you know it's like innovative ways to
say no to somebody yeah yeah but
you know
I was taught my friend uh uh I was with
my friend mookie Thompson the other
night we were at Stress Factory in New
Brunswick and uh
the owner at Vinnie brand asked me a
very similar question about like what's
it like you know that must have been
tough right now it's like and mookie
said perfectly it's like no that that's
what's made in
so focused and able to pursue comedy in
the sense I got this rock a Gibraltar at
home well I don't need to be thinking
about publicity and chasing girls and
all this kind of [ __ ] like I got I got
what I want need at home already like
I'ma just stay focused on the game uh uh
ensure like Naomi Campbell hasn't come
knocking yet
yeah you know there's still time but uh
uh if Doja cat wants to holler we can
have a conversation but
keep spitting him out he was spinning
out as well shoot your shot dude who are
your uh Dwayne Johnson hit me up you
know like I'll [ __ ] do it yeah who
are your hall passes
Dojo uh uh but beyond you know like no
you know the the answer is no like
that's cool if anything like I'm more on
my
game because I I know what's gonna come
to a certain extent like a very famous
friends all this kind of so I just kind
of see what happens I'm like oh I know
how to avoid this and that trap and I
was like I don't go out after shows I
don't hang out I'll have a drink maybe
or two but beyond that like
I'm ghost I go home wow
before it's over if you had to stab
anyone in the world who would it be so I
had to murder somebody yeah I said stab
don't take it out of context they don't
have to die just hurt somebody
if I had this step kind of question stab
a circle around the heart like that
you don't damage the heart though yeah
so don't worry the heart's okay bring
yourself it's like the knife is like a
love knife too you know what I mean just
so it feels a little better it's
absolutely the world if I had to stab
anybody okay just [ __ ] slap him like
Will Smith babe
Mitch McConnell I think would make a
good step
he makes a good step yeah like right
right we're beneath like above this part
like right here in between his shell he
knows
Turtle ass mother like might [ __ ]
break that shell off
shout out to Mitch McConnell
I think that would be fun uh I wouldn't
I do not want to murder Mitch McConnell
please I that's not a death threat at
all okay I hope Mitch McConnell lives a
very short life but
[Laughter]
he's already he's been [ __ ] around
for eight billion years
because the time is coming yeah yeah
that was a hot one now sweating a little
bit
[Music]